sie müssen sich ganz hinten anstellen
den künstler an der front die show über
lassen nachher schnell wieder anbauen so
sehen schwerst arbeiterinnen aus die von
der männlich geprägten musikindustrie
nicht immer honoriert werden die ganze
zeit und zu singen mal witzig sein
ich wollte mir aber so nicht mein geld
verteilen mary clayton ist eine feste
größe im business und sang mit stars wie
den rolling stones dem song gimme
shelter wärs sie eine unverkennbare note
ich bekam einen anruf mary er ist eine
gruppe von typen irgendwer dann kann sie
lockenwicklern direkt aus dem bett was
sie singen musste war ziemlich heftig
sagte wie bitte vergewaltigung wort nur
einen schuss entfernt also sagte ich mir
jetzt werde ich sie erst recht aus dem
studio posten
doch die besten empfehlungen halfen
nichts der weg zur solokarriere gerät
ins stocken
das gesetz gilt einmal macworld immer
bei krems und der hat seine eigenen
regeln der dress code heißt du musst die
männer geil machen
heiß aussehen die männer bezirzen
das war der job der ipads der background
gruppe hinter eickhorn seine frau tina
hat den weg nach vorne geschafft
das wollte auch die new yorkerin lisa
fischer erreichen
das ausnahmetalent sind unter anderem
mit den rolling stones und sting im film
erlebt der zuschauer mit ihr eine
achterbahnfahrt der gefühle
wird sie es schaffen es sind keine
fairen voraussetzungen
es geht weder um fairness noch ein
talent es sind die umstände glück sein
schicksal
ich weiß es nicht die besten müssen
damit umgehen können
lisa fischer ist zweifellos einer der
besten
eine stimme zum dahinschmelzen
es ist die stärke des films den
zuschauer mit heldinnen wie ihr auf die
ganz große karriere hoffen zu lassen
und es sind immer wieder magische
momente wenn rockgrößen wie sting für
sie aus dem rampenlicht zurück trieb
sie hat eine wahnsinnsstimme sie ist ein
star
das war hieß es da
und tatsächlich zunächst sieht es gut
für sie aus
sie nimmt ihr erstes solo album auf und
gewinnt 1992 dafür einen grammy
bald muss aber auch sie begreifen ihre
hammer stimme reicht leider nicht zum
großen durchbruch
ich war dabei meine zweite platte
aufzunehmen und dann dauert es einfach
zu lange
ich konnte nicht schnell genug nachlegen
talent ist in diesem harten business
einfach nicht alles
ich kenne so viele menschen mit
herausragenden stimme aber wenn du
niemanden findest du verstehst du bist
kannst du zu eine tolle sängerin sein
aber einfach den nächsten schritt nicht
schaffen
sie sind eben keine stars einfach tolle
sängerinnen mit dieser tatsache müssen
sie leben und dem wissen dass sie
oftmals die besseren stimmen haben als
die berühmtheiten vorjahr
umso besser wenn ihnen die begeisterung
für singen bleibt und die vermittelt
dieser stimmgewaltige film